I told my son and like when you get in
trouble for not picking up your toys do
you want me to kill you
and he completely understood what I
meant by we shouldn't just shoot people
because we think they've done something
bad
Shannon is the world the stars the moon
the galaxies my son is the reason why
I'm breathing he reminds me to breathe
actually he tells me to take deep
breaths and I love every moment with him
the idea that she could be taken from me
the only reaction I have is to fight
that like why would somebody take her
from me what makes me hesitate or
uncomfortable about raising another
black child in American society is that
by sheer virtue of my child having brown
skin or black skin they'll be seen as a
threat in our own space at home others
peace is love but in terms of the
outside of that space and we live in a
system of white supremacy so it's
definitely uncomfortable it's not just
police brutality I'm worried about I'm
worried about the system and the
practices and policies that put black
children at a disadvantage from our
early age
our life doesn't matter why people are
more important I'm not pretty I'm not
valuable I was trying to talk to a bunch
of mothers and fathers at once just
brothers and sisters and I was trying to
get there and say I have value and they
couldn't even say it some couldn't even
write it down my heart still breaks for
like Tamir rice a child was murdered in
cold blood in broad daylight at a park I
saw my son in him I read that the
four-year-old daughter of the man that
was killed had to console the mother my
son is too it was about to be three I
can't imagine him witnessing my own
death I think there are a lot of
messages that parents are taking from
this you have some that feel oh if I
just make sure my child is educated oh
if I just make sure my black child lives
in a better neighborhood oh as long as I
make sure you know my child knows what
it is to completely comply I mean they
might as well just say yes Massah to me
you do have this list of things that
they tell black people do like you know
always be respectful yes sir put the
hands up don't do this don't do that but
we know that's a lie they kill you for
no reason
literally just because they made oh I
feared him well I know for the parents
around myself we are being activated
into organizing and bringing our
children with us and let her know to
take pride take pride in her skin take
pride in her hair take pride in then all
that she is I'm a dancer I'm instilling
in her what she needs to know to protect
her - it reaffirmed that she is mighty
so in the event that she becomes you
know twelve sixteen seventeen she's
walking down the street
and someone guns her down I know that
that was beyond my control my son can
die at the hands of the police
I can die at the hands of the police
just for being blacks that's a reality
that I have to live with my
five-year-old he understands he asked me
Mommy are you gonna get shot by the
police and he was playing with his you
know white friend around the same age
and the white friend you know pulls up
his hand and it's like oh I got a shot
by the doctor and you can just see the
disparity of the lives that they're
living you don't think oh my child can't
walk to the store and he's gonna die on
the way back you try not to you want
them to have the best quality of life
and the best quality of life isn't being
like no I can't go outside we don't have
time to be engaged in intellectual
masturbating dealing with the system in
terms of police brutality we need a
standard at the federal level some type
of standard protocol in which every
Police Department has to abide by I
can't imagine the system that we have
right now for my son to grow up safely
I'm gonna try my best to share with my
son the realities of his life and
hopefully he better navigate it with
wisdom and in love if we it just
internalized and became so aware of
black power one we wouldn't be sitting
here trying to convince people who we
are and that we have that we're like
okay you know what you come see me when
you're ready to make some changes